Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Welcome back.
Grab a hold of a workbook and let's tackle this. A tough day, tough topic.
Let's tackle it, okay? Here's today's theme in day number 11.
"The corruption of the human heart is the enemy of
holiness."
I've got a math problem for you to solve, okay? Ready? Go.
He's like, "Well, I can't solve that problem.
I don't even know what the problem is." Yeah, I know.
If you've ever had car problems,
how many of you have just raised the hood and stood there staring?
Just standing there staring into the engine compartment, kind of hoping something
will fix itself, right? Dave Barry, one of my favorite humor
writers, says when his car breaks down, he said, "I pull over and I
raise the hood and stare thoughtfully into the engine compartment." He said, "I'm
not sure what I'm looking for. I'm always hoping it's going to be something
obvious, like a squid clinging to the manifold."
Like, "Oh, well, here's the problem. There's a squid on the manifold.
Well, that's easy. Let's get that off of there and this thing should work fine."
Now some of you are trying to solve the problem
called you,
right? And you're trying to solve that problem, and you got smoke pouring out from
under the hood, and you're sitting there staring under the hood, or you're just
driving on hoping it's going to fix itself.
And trying to solve the problem called you has lost
you 10 years or 20 years, two to three relationships, jobs,
friendships.
The problem is not that we don't know what to do, it's that we
don't know why we don't do it.
Right? Do you really need someone to tell you, "Don't look at
that stuff. It's just going to pollute your mind and wreck your relationship"?
Do you really need that? Do you really need somebody to tell you,
"That substance, if you keep drinking or smoking it, is going to steal your
happiness, wreck your body, and make everything in your life worse"?
No. We already know that.
Do you really need somebody to tell you that selfishness is going to
keep your marriage unhappy?
Do you really need somebody to say, "Your anger is going to break your relationship
with your kids and make them just like you"?
No, we already know that. The problem is that we don't know what to
do, it's that we can't make ourselves do it,
and we don't know why.
Maybe the problem
is that you don't know what the problem is.
The problem is that you don't know what the problem is.
So stick with me for the next few days because we're going to take a hard look in
the engine compartment and we're going to see what the problem is.
We're going to figure out what the problem is so God can fix you, all right?
I want to start in an unlikely place with a country song by Tim McGraw,
okay? That really recognizes and puts the problem in an interesting way.
Tim McGraw wrote a song or performed a song called "The Cowboy in Me." Here's what
it says, "I don't know why I act the way I do,
like I ain't got a single thing to lose.
Sometimes I'm my own worst enemy.
I guess that's just the cowboy in me.
The urge to run, the restlessness, the heart of stone I
sometimes get. The things I've done for foolish
pride. The me that's never
satisfied. The face that's in the mirror when I don't like what
I see.
I guess that's just the cowboy in me."
Now, those are really profound lyrics, because that's a pretty good
description, pretty good explanation of the sin nature.
People who are not Christians, they try to explain away their sinful nature by
blaming it on their environment or their spouse.
Something outside themselves.
"Ah, it's just my personality, it's my upbringing, it's my parents didn't potty
train me right when I was three, and I've been warped ever since," right?
Sometimes people who are Christians try to explain it away
using some other method. They just rename it, right?
"Oh, I'm not angry and yelling and being unloving.
I'm speaking forcefully because I'm righteously indignant.
Oh, I'm not gossiping. I'm sharing prayer needs.
Oh, I'm not speaking unkindly. I'm just bringing the truth that nobody else
dares to say.
I'm not proud, I've just got really great self-image.
Well, I'm not worrying, I'm just..." You get the point, right?
We rename and relabel things.
Now, here's the thing. This sinful nature is
hardwired into your mind, your soul, your psyche.
It's not like a bolt-on or a plug-in or an add-on.
It's part of the operating system.
It is the way it's done. In theology, it's called the
sin nature. It's a noun that results
in verbs. It's the sin that results in sinning.
It's a nature that results in actions and
attitudes.
All sin in action flows out of the sin nature.
In Psalm 58:3, it says, "Even from birth the wicked go astray.
They are wayward from the womb spreading
lies." You see it? That sin nature is there from birth.
Nobody holds a cute little newborn and says, "Aw, what a cute little
liar."
But they are.
They're not a liar because they chose to lie.
They will someday choose to lie because they are
liars. I've heard my dad explain it like this.
Imagine a barnyard animal, kind of a pink color with a
chopped-off nose and four little short legs and a little curly tail. Right?
You know what animal I'm talking about?
If you took that animal and you put it out in the barnyard and said, "Now, animal,
listen.
If you go over and wallow in that mud hole over there, you're going to become a
pig."
No, that's not the way it works, right?
He goes and wallows in the mud hole because he's already a pig.
He's got a pig nature that pulls him into the mud hole
In the same way, we're not sinful because we choose to sin.
No.
We sin because we're sinful. Let's go a step further.
Psalm 51:5, David says, "Surely I was sinful at birth,
sinful from the moment my mother conceived me." So
before you had even developed eyelids, your whole self had
an influence that was going to drag you into sin.
Isaiah talks about it as self-sovereignty.
Look at Isaiah 53:6, "We all, like sheep,
have gone astray, and each one of us has turned into his
own way."
I think this passage really nails the problem.
The cowboy in me
is self-sovereignty. The problem isn't that I have a will.
God has a will. Jesus had a will. It's that my
will is set on autopilot toward a
destination that reads, "My way."
It's that our autopilot assumption is that
we're in charge of our life, that we are naturally self-sovereign, and it
shows up in the self sins. And we'll discuss
those things tomorrow. All right? We're going to discuss that.
Don't get discouraged here. Don't
leave me. All right? This is a hard thing, but consider
this carefully because Jeremiah
says in Jeremiah 17:3 that no one can
really understand the sinful heart of man
because it disguises itself. We're going to talk more about this,
but
I want you to not skip over considering this
and asking the Lord, asking the Holy Spirit to
unveil why you do what you do.
If there's a cowboy in me still in your heart,
you got to see it.
You got to see it, even when it hurts and it's painful to look at, and like, "I
don't want to see that. I don't want to notice that's why I do these things." But
you got to see it because we can't clean out the wound if we don't
look, and we can't heal if we don't clean out the wound.
So let's not get discouraged. Let's look at it.
Let's look honestly at it and consider and ask the Lord to reveal to us that
which is hidden from our eyes. Lord, is there a
cowboy in me?
See you tomorrow.